[Musica]
ciao ragazzi scusate non mi stavo
proprio aspettando sono solo umilia
muscillo qualcuno di voi si ricorderà di
me per nitriti casalini e la mia rubrica
che esce sul settimanale casa in
montagna e puledri nani qualcun altro
ancora mi avrà visto nella nuova serie
tv che vede come protagonista il
coraggio di essere tutta pepe qualcun
altro ancora invece forse si ricorderà
della mia vittoria a sanremo l'anno
scorso con il brano montami polli
scritto da rupert everett e cantato
insieme a paolo fox e il 2018 è iniziato
da da un mese ormai ma chi mi conosce
bene sa che questo non mi fermerà
assolutamente dal farvi un augurio per
il nuovo anno e soprattutto darvi
qualche consiglio per renderli più
felici nella vita perché questo quello
che dove auguro quello di imparare ad
amarmi di più giorno dopo giorno
ecco perché ho deciso in armi i cinque
consigli pratici da seguire cinque
consigli da parte di uno che nella vita
ce l'ha fatto ma soprattutto
consiglio numero uno imparate a pensare
con la vostra testa troppe persone oggi
sviluppano un opinione di sé stesse
sulla base di quello che gli altri
pensano di loro ecco quanto conte volte
avreste voluto magari indossare quel
bellissimo vestito lungo di paillettes
con uno spacco che arrivava fino a
lingue magari per andare un funerale e
poi c'è stato il classico amico che
aveva sconsigliato di fare una cosa di
questo tipo
beh in quel caso il nostro amico ha
fatto una cosa saggia perché il vostro
cattivo gusto avrebbe fatto impallidire
dio
ecco magari se avesse avuto io ho un
amico di questo tipo quando ho deciso di
recarmi capelli molto probabilmente oggi
sono sempre un carciofo ma di base
cercate di rimanere fedeli a voi stessi
michael jackson molto probabilmente non
sarebbe mai riuscito a diventare
un'icona mondiale se avesse ascoltato
tutte le persone che dicevano di tenersi
attaccato il naso alla faccia o una
persona per esempio come donald trump
non sarebbe oggi il presidente degli
stati uniti d'america
se i suoi genitori fosse riuscito a
inculcare nella testa quand'era piccolo
che resta dei valori come la parità
l'uguaglianza la tolleranza e rispetto
pensare con la propria testa è
sicuramente il primo passo da compiere
per amare se stessi consiglio numero 2
seguite sempre le vostre passioni
non ascoltate mai tutte quelle persone
che magari mi dicono che non sarete
nessuno anche quando hanno ragione tutti
quelli che sono diventati qualcuno
all'inizio non erano nessuno non fatevi
una computare giù da quelli che
criticano tutto quello che fate tutto
quello che vi piace è normale
normalissimo per i frustrati provare
rancore e odio nei confronti di chi
cerca la felicità
magari se attila avesse scoperto
qualcosa tipo la passione per il cucito
non avrebbe mai e poi mai spronato i
suoi figli o se niro ne avesse ma che
riscoperto la passione per lo sci di
fondo e l'adrenalina che tira non
avrebbe mai e poi mai bruciato roma e
perché no
il grande conti blood dracula avrebbe
mai imparato tutte quelle persone se
avesse scoperto il piacere della
stimolazione prostatica
o magari lo avrebbe fatto ma solo come
tali dalla punta arrotondata parte le
persone felici le persone che seguono le
loro passioni non vanno in giro a
seminare terrore e morte nel mondo
ci avete pensato avere consiglio numero
33 del vostro cuore l'amore poteri che
appare carvi da un momento all'altro
tomba e non state lì ad ascoltare i
vostri amici che si lamentano sempre
perché non credono i sentimenti che sono
single
poi trova il giro prendo le persone le
buttala via come se fossero coriandoli
le persone non sono mica un obiettivo
per bambini da che cosa credete
e nemmeno state ad ascoltare tutti i
vostri amici poneva reolon quelli che
stanno a casa con piatto che si
lamentano e non siano mai una
possibilità per favore loro momento e un
affetto molto probabilmente ma voi sì
come potete come potete pensare di non
credere nell'amore e aspettare che
questo crede in voi aprite il vostro
cuore anche se fa paura
e quando siete nel dubbio rileggete le
gesta di cleopatra si assume con
marcantonio fosse andato bene
secondo voi si sarebbe forse uccisa
facendosi mordere da un terribi chi se
non credo consiglio numero 4 spegnete
quel cellulare è risaputo che passare
ore al telefono oltre che diminuire la
fertilità diminuisca anche la voglia di
vivere
insomma passare ogni sera a guardare la
vacanza di giulia alle maldive o un
fisichetto che ha tirato su marco o
ancora peggio il meraviglioso matrimonio
di paolo e francesca sono tutte cose che
non rientrano assolutamente nell'inizio
ha mediato stima cui avremmo bisogno
internet è un po come una finestra verso
il mondo ma spesso quello che vediamo
coltrane avanzate
non è vero ecco perché vi invito a
spegnere quel cellulare prima che
rischiate di bottardi ci da quella
finestra
siete più sociali e meno social alla
fine che valore ha
ancora su instagram
se non riuscite commettervi un like
quando vi guardate allo specchio
consiglio numero 5 magnate magnate
magnate da far schifo per chi mangia fa
bene alla salute e soprattutto delizioso
soprattutto mangiate senza sentirvi ogni
volta e colpo pesante la bilancio di
mamme e promesso quattro consigli
gentilmente dai butto giù la pasta
ragazzi ma costa fregnaccia
[Musica]